por favor Pase Ana Vera integrante del
colectivo proaborto Sur cuna escucha el
reclamo de una madre que busca apoyo
para su hija de 13 años que fue violada
entiéndame que es una niña y tampoco
tengo esta menor conforme a la lista de
113 niñas y adolescentes que son madres
cada día en Ecuador según el Instituto
Nacional de estadística un número
alarmante que inquieta a las ongs
nosotras con sentencia acompañamos
veintidós casos más o menos de mujeres
niñas sobre todo que necesitaban acceder
a un aborto por violación y después de
que se expedido la ley el Ministerio ha
reportado que solamente se han hecho
ocho abortos por causar violación
ley a la que no quiso someterse esta
otra mujer que naciste a su médico de
confianza 750 abortos médicos Se
realizaron en Ecuador durante el año
2021 según la Fuente oficial este médico
cuestiona el estado por no considerar la
salud de manera integral las
consecuencias físicas mentales y
psicológicas de un embarazo no deseado
el aborto Debería ser legal
y regulado eso científicamente ya sea
comprobado que no aumenta a los la tasa
de abortos Amparo Medina ex activista
Pro aborto no apoya esta postura después
de cambiar su manera de pensar Busca
persuadir a las mujeres de abortar
ofreciendo preparación para el parto
alimentación atención médica psicológica
ilegal gratuita para ella la ley no
Resuelve los niveles de pobreza
desnutrición y desempleo a las que se
ven expuestas algunas jóvenes que
deciden interrumpir su embarazo
es darles las posibilidades para que
ellas puedan emprender puedan también
tener recursos apoyarles en el área
laboral en el área de emprendimientos
personales en el año 2021 nacieron en
Ecuador
41.295 niños de madres de 10 a 19 años
de edad según la Fuente oficial
457 madres tenían menos de 14 años para
las activistas la ley debe ser declarada
inconstitucional por no cumplir con los
parámetros internacionales de Derechos
Humanos por lo que se espera otra lucha
para abrir el camino hacia un nuevo
texto legal